[Music]
as coronavirus shut down the global
economy
the value of american stocks plummeted
in the weeks that followed covert 19
killed
tens of thousands of americans
racial unrest tore through the country
and a record 23 million were out of work
but the stock market climbed and climbed
by june 8 it had gained 38
since its low point in mid-march
this idea that the stock market and the
economy should move in tandem
suggests that we're all in this together
and
this divergence belays bear that that is
not the case
so why is the value of american stock so
seemingly cut off
from current events and what does this
tell us about the wider economy
in the 400 years stock markets have been
around
their basic function hasn't really
changed
the purpose of the stock market is for
firms to be able to raise capital
to invest and grow larger and more
successful and more efficient
there are stock exchanges all over the
world
the largest is the new york stock
exchange on which companies worth
21 trillion dollars are listed
[Music]
the fortunes of companies listed on this
exchange
and the lives of ordinary americans used
to be more closely aligned
in the 1950s the new york stock exchange
made a concerted effort
to tempt small investors who had been
scared off by the wall street crash of
1929
investors all over the country use the
facilities of brokers who are members of
the new york stock exchange
whenever they want to buy or sell stock
of companies
listed on this national market
[Music]
in the 1950s 90 percent of the stock
market
or more was held by sort of small retail
investors
and so you had these sort of two
feedback effects one was if the economy
was doing well firms were doing well
stock prices would rise
and the other one was well when stock
prices were rising people would feel
wealthier
we had these dual links that meant that
the stock market and the economy
the the health of both tended to move
together
in 2020 things look very different
and american stock markets and the
economy seem poles apart
to understand why look at the indices
that track the value of companies
whose stock is being traded when you
talk about the value of stocks the value
of the stock market
uh what most people are really talking
about is the value of these indices and
probably the most famous one in america
is the s p 500 which
is the value of america's 500 largest
publicly listed firms all being equal
the value of an index will rise if the
companies it tracks are expected
to do well the value of the s p 500
has mainly been climbing since march
this is partly due to the fact
it includes some of the world's largest
and most successful technology companies
facebook apple microsoft amazon
and alphabet google's parent company
and these companies have thrived during
the pandemic
which has boosted the overall value of
the smp
any stock market index that has
a lot of technology companies in it will
probably have been sort of less
damaged by the pandemic than
than indices that don't have those
companies in them
and that's not necessarily anything to
do with
the american economy recovering from
the pandemic better their sort of
business models seem fundamentally
less impacted by the pandemic possibly
even helped in the case of
firms that provide software or firms
that deliver goods to your
home
but the performance of the smp is not
simply driven by these tech
giants early march
overall share prices in companies listed
here were falling
and the s p only rallied the day after
the federal reserve
america's central bank announced it
would be stepping in
with a series of enormous aid packages
to help prevent
economic disaster we have acted to
safeguard financial markets in order to
provide stability to the financial
system
and to support the flow of credit in the
economy
the fed created new money to buy
corporate bonds
and lend to companies allowing
businesses to borrow cash
on an almost unprecedented scale
and while the impact of the fed's
actions is taking time to play out in
the real economy
share prices rallied almost immediately
the s p 500 recorded the biggest week of
gains in more than four decades
this is a fed rally this is not an
earnings rally
a lot of the power in what the fed does
is
in the signaling value it basically
stacks the deck against things
continuing
to decline and so when you get that sort
of signal from the fed
it it makes it much sort of safer i
guess to buy stocks
stock markets are forward-looking as
share prices
are based on investor predictions so
it's not unusual for them to rally long
before the real economy picks up
but while the course of a normal
recession is relatively predictable
the economic consequences of a pandemic
and lockdowns
are much harder to price
the hard reality is this
is not even close to being over
and some fear the fed's actions have
created a false sense of optimism
we really have no idea how long
this economic damage will last
it does feel like we have got genuinely
sort of more bad news perhaps this idea
of a second wave or an extended first
wave in america
that will mean that the economic damage
will be bigger than we thought it would
be
in march and that doesn't seem to have
sort of popped
the market's bubble
the way stock prices have risen also
creates an awkward side effect for
policy makers
the fed's actions prevented economic
catastrophe
and emergency support provided by
congress actually pushed the poverty
rate down
but the fact that the stimulus packages
caused the value of shares on the snp to
rise
has inevitably disproportionately
benefited the rich
when the fed steps in and sort of
increases the amount of money
in an economy in a crisis what you tend
to see is the value of assets go up
even as the real economy struggles
and this it does feel very unfair
most americans own stock through
investment plans like pensions
but the wealth of the rich is far more
concentrated in stocks
88 of those earning over 100 000
per year own stock as opposed to 19
of those earning under 35 000 a year
and the vast majority of all stocks
owned by americans belong to the
wealthiest 10
of households the fed couldn't have not
bailed out
firms and um markets because the the
damage that that would have wrought for
everyone rich and paul would have been
much worse than the
the alternative but it is a very
uncomfortable
dynamic for policy makers because of
this sort of link between what they can
do in asset prices
they they seemingly have to help
everyone by helping in particular rich
the smp's recent meteoric rise has now
leveled off
but ultimately the fate of both stock
markets and the economy are tied
and as america begins to reckon with the
long-term impact of the pandemic
the health of both will depend on how
and when the federal stimulus is
eventually reduced
and how quickly a vaccine becomes
available
i'm alice forward i'm the economist wall
street correspondent
if you want to read more about curving
19 and how it's affecting the economy
then please click the link opposite